on reçoit ce soir dit cormier le pdg de
desjardins qu'on retrouve à lévis ce
soir bonsoir monsieur cormier
morceaux de ses filiales vous avez comme
d'autres institutions beaucoup aider vos
membres à faire face à la pandémie c'est
pour ça notamment que les provisions
pour pertes sur crédit étaient quand
même plus élevé l'eau dans le passé et
moins en 2021 par rapport à l'inflation
qui préoccupe beaucoup les gens en ce
moment qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que vous
faites par rapport à l'inflation ppi la
hausse des taux d'intérêt est également
qui s'en vient
bah écoutez on fait le tour de notre
portefeuille actuellement quand on
regarde le portefeuille des crédits du
mouvement desjardins le portefeuille est
de grande qualité nous avons constaté
qu'ils aient membres au cours des deux
dernières années augmenté
significativement leur niveau des palmes
alors qu on voit une réduction des
soldes sur les cartes de crédit donc ce
s'amène au monde dans une posture encore
plus proactive pour passer à travers une
période plus inflationniste on évalue
peut-être la has à 7% de la portefeuille
d'emprunteurs qui pourrait juste bien
pourrait avoir des difficultés s'il y
avait des hausses rapides de taux
d'intérêt est-ce qu'on est déjà en
action on les adapte absolument faux
absolument pas c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup dans la mesure où ces gens là
ont une certaine capacité à passer à
travers le jeu pour inquiéter les jeunes
à ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
proactivement on va déjà regardé dans la
situation de ces gens-là et l'effet que
j'en ai beaucoup plus épargné à une
utilisation de leur cas beaucoup moins
forte ça les met dans une posture qui
selon nous est plus favorable puis le
taux d'intérêt il ya des gens qui ont
une capacité des gens ont qualifié nos
membres avec des taux d'intérêt plus
élevé depuis les dernières années alors
on demeure positif mais on va être
proactif provient accompagné de membres
comme peu d'eau parce que les taux
d'intérêts monsieur
monsieur cormier les taux hypothécaires
sont déjà à la hausse les taux d'intérêt
vont monter au cours des deux prochaines
années dont les gens vont sentir ça il
ya eu un tel engouement immobilier
depuis des deux ans et des jardins bien
sûr en a profiter parce qu'il eut
beaucoup d'hypothèques qui ont été
signés et renouveler il ya des gens
nécessairement qu'ils doivent se dire
attention la hausse des taux d'intérêt
sans vient ça pourrait me frapper
durement
absolue mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les au cours des dernières années les
gens qui ont contracté une hypothèque
avec le mouvement desjardins ont calculé
leurs capacités de payer non pas
seulement sur le taux actif à ce moment
là mais on allait augmenter le taux
d'intérêt pour voir s'il était capable
d'accepter ou de soutenir une hausse de
taux d'intérêt donc ça leur donnait déjà
d'une certaine marge de manoeuvre et on
a chez desjardins peut-être seulement
20% de notre portefeuille qui arrive en
renouvellement cette année donc vous
avez des acheteurs qui ont acheté dans
les 2-3 dans leurs années qui ont pris
les hypothèques sur 85 ans certains dans
certains cas - ne seront pas
nécessairement impacté par les hausses
de taux d'intérêt qui pourrait se
produire au cours des prochains
trimestres donc la situation oui elle
est à suivre mais mais il ya des gens
qui sont quand même en bonne posture
pour passer à travers cette hausse vous
vous entrez dans le dernier droit à la
tête de desjardins si je me trompe pas
il reste deux ans à votre mandat c'est
quoi votre priorité pour les deux
prochaines années
la priorité va à être vraiment de
poursuivre sur notre croissance et sur
notre transformation la priorité c'est
nos membres on a augmenté
significativement nos investissements en
technologie en sécurité en oeuvre des
services donc on veut continuer d'être
dans le contact vous l'avez vu notre
notre croissance et est quand même très
très très forte cette année remarquable
les membres ne font confiance alors on
va continuer d'investir pour rendre
notre offre toujours compétitive et
après ici nos membres et clients la
deuxième chose c'est qu'avec la
capitalisation que nous avons on va
poursuivre notre croissance à travers le
canada notamment en assurance de
dommages avec nos assureurs vie pour
justement se donner la capacité
additionnelle des trucs de pouvoir
offrir de meilleurs services et le
secteur entreprises nous avons une
croissance de plus de 13% cette année en
entreprise dans le marché québécois
accompagner nos entrepreneurs qui
veulent croître à l'international
on va être là pour les faire des
acquisitions donc dans l'assurance de
dommages c'est ça c'est le monstre un
marché qui selon nous va continuer de se
consolider nous sommes déjà le deuxième
plus important assureur automobile
habitation à travers le canada nous
voulons rester dans cette posture de
leadership là et oui on a la capacité
financière de poursuivre avec des
acquisitions mais déjà notre croissance
à long terme est très forte sur le vol
de données de 2019 monsieur cormier il
ya une entente de plus de 200 millions
de dollars qui a été conclu entre
desjardins et les initiateurs des
actions collectives qui avait été
intentée est ce que cette entente la met
fin à cette histoire est ce que cette
histoire là est terminée pour vous
écouter premièrement on est très content
que cette entente on va voir maintenant
ce que la cour au mois de mai ou juin va
statuer le processus est en cours pour
nous la sécurité c'est jamais terminé
nous avons augmenté significativement
nos investissements nous continuons de
faire preuve de leadership
nous avons notre protection des jardins
qui accompagnent les membres et clients
qui sont victimes d'une situation qu'ils
soient chez desjardins ou ailleurs on va
continuer d accompagner alors la cyber
sécurité c'est un travail sans fin et
non ce n'est pas terminé on va continuer
d'investir et les membres qui ont
continué de nous faire confiance il n'y
a pas eu de changements depuis 2010 neuf
chiens les a remerciés regardez les
résultats c est ce que c'est vrai ce que
les employés de desjardins reviendrons
bientôt siège social de lévis au
complexe desjardins notamment
centre-ville de montréal ailleurs au
québec aussi
bah écoutez avec les mesures sanitaires
qui se relâchent leur dès le mois de
mars nous allons recommencer à mettre
nos modes de travail hybride en place
dans nos caisses desjardins les gens ont
toujours été au rendez-vous d'ailleurs
je félicite nos employés dans le réseau
des caisses qui ont fait preuve d'une
grande proximité avec nos membres pour
les accompagner mais dans les endroits
que ce soit lévis montréal toronto
mississauga vancouver
les gens vont graduellement à partir du
mois de mars revenir dans un modèle
hybride soit une journée deux journées
trois journaux bus roulent mais oui on
va on va réactiver la personne
physiquement
merci beaucoup monsieur cormier d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir merci merci
beaucoup monsieur thierno sy si on
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit